サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナササナナン
ではよろしくお願いします
はい 今日のテーマは どうして仲良くできないの？ということなんですね
これはちょっと話が皆様が期待するところからかなり脱線してしまいますから
先にいくらかポイントを言いたいと思います
大体私たちはね この世の中でなんとか仲良くする方法はないのかとかね
人間関係うまくいく方法はないのかって
これ単純な考えしか持ってないんですね
で それかこれは至って簡単ですから
私は説明しません なぜかというと
この自分の都合で 自分の利益で
自分のために自分のメリットを考えて
人と仲良くしたいんですよ
だから そんな程度はもう誰だって知ってるし
どんな本見なくてもわかるしね
これ 偉大なる超越したブッダの智慧
智慧を紹介するところですから
一般的なちょっと理解できないというかね
一般的には全然聞くこと聞くチャンスがないものを説明したいんです
で ですから まず一般論を喋ってます
あの どうして仲良くできないのと
仲良くできないんです
答えは 人間には で その理由は
この差別と区別の違いを知っておけば
まあ仲良くできるんですね
区別 差別と区別 で 英語で言えばディファレンスアンドディスクリミネーションですね
この 2つをちゃんと知っておけば問題は解決する
だから その時点から 俗世間で皆様いろんなこの自己啓発本などでうなどで見るものとは違うんですね
そこでまあ 本当の答え
まあ英語で書いてありますから
それぐらいの英語は読めるでしょうね
ビーウェア マンカインドイズボントゥキル
ビーウェアというのはもう気をつけろよと
人類は殺すために生きてるんだと
殺し屋と マンカインドなんて人類な人間なんですね
だから まあ私は面白いんだから
何でもちょっと極端で
ちょっと言い過ぎになりならない
そこそこのところまで言いますけど
私の言葉はだいたい言い過ぎだなと感じたっても
意味はその通りなんです
これ優しく言っちゃうと
なんか面白くないしね
心に残らないんですね
だからこういうフレーズなんかは人間に覚えられますよ
覚えてると役に立ちますよ
マンカインドイズボントゥキルとかね
殺す目的で生まれてるんだと
はい これでポイントわかると思いますね
私たちは生まれる時も他を潰す
殺す 破壊する精神で生まれるんです
だからこれ簡単な問題じゃないんです
だからなんか脳がおかしいんですよ
生まれる時ももうおかしいんです
生まれた赤ちゃんにとっては何も殺せませんだけど
まだ大脳できてないし
でも古い脳がね 原始脳のところはもうしっかりできてますからね
これがわがままで自分のことしか感じないんですね
だから考える能力は大きくなってから
大脳が開発すると考えるようになります
考えなくても生きていられます
だから赤ちゃんしっかり生きてるんです
動物たちもしっかり生きてるんです
だから大脳の判断がなければ大変やってことはないんですよ
我々人間でもね 認知障害になったってもね
何もわからないでしょ
自分の名前さえもわからない
でもちゃんと生きてるんです
それの全然問題ないんです
自分の名前さえ忘れてるんです
だから大脳で入れたデータ一切忘れている
代わりに古いの原始の私は獣の脳と言うんですけどね
それが元気なんです だから認知症の方々はやっぱり怒る時は怒るわ
笑う時は笑うわ まあでもあなたの名前は？と言ったらわかりません
自分の子供の顔もわからないということになっちゃうんです
はい そういうことで 私たちはね
とても危険な存在で だから自分を開発してければ
まずそれを覚えてほしい
私は本来危険な存在であると
もう何の理由もなく ただ相手を侮辱したい
相手を攻撃したい 相手を馬鹿にしたい
それしか感じない これは考えじゃないんです
気持ちなんです 気持ちでは自分がもうトップグレードで
もう完璧で素晴らしくて
何の欠点もないんですね
気持ち的には 考えることになってくると
口先ではそうではないと言いますけどね
だから自分が完璧だから
世の中を見てみると まあそうどうしても不完全で邪魔で馬鹿でアホで見えるんですね
くだらなくておかしくて
で それでそれにまず出てくる気持ちが
もう相手を馬鹿にしたい
いじめたい 潰したい 壊したいという気持ちが先に来るんですね
それで壊したいんだけど壊せないという感じになってくると
自分が怖くなるんですね
引っ込んだりするんですね
怯えたりするんです で
それが誰にだって最初にある気持ちなんですね
大体どんな人間でもね
最初に公で何か喋ろうとかね
大きな発表をしようとかね
なんとかなってくると偉い緊張するんですね
で なんで緊張するんですかね
その場合は やっぱり向こう側から何か言われたら
受けなかったら 自分の発表はと
怖くなるんですね 自分が完璧な自我を持ってないならば
そんなことはね どうってことないんです
自分の発表を受けなかったと
まあしょうがないやと
発表そのものは良くなかったと
それだけの話ですけど
やっぱり引っ込んだり落ち込んだりする
で 私のことを認めてくれないと泣いてる人もいるでしょうにね
それも同じことなんですね
だから この 自我をとにかくしっかりとできてるんだとね
確認してほしいんですね
だから私は完璧な完璧な
とても優れている存在やということが
もう嘘で幻覚でアホでバカだからそう思ってるんだけど
思ってないんですね そう感じているんだからね
フィーリングだから 思ってるところは誰もそんな馬鹿なこと思ってないんです
思ってないんだから なんで自分のことを認めてないと落ち込むんですかね
なぜ自分の仕事はこれダメだ
これはとかね 間違いでしょと言われたら
すっごくもうガクンと落ち込んじゃうんですね
あれはなんですかね 頭であんと思ってますかね
あんたの正しいやつ いいえ
そんなこと思ってないよと言うんだけど
気持ちどうですかね だから気持ちがそうさせてるんですね
だから気持ちと思考を別々にしましょう
我々は赤ちゃんでお腹の中で生まれてから
もうこの気持ちがしっかりできていて
これがとんでもないものなんです
間違いなんです だから
人間が仲良くしようと思うならば
我々は最初からもうそれをよく気をつけて
頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで人と頑張るんじゃないんです
自分一人で この中の気持ちと戦わなくちゃあかんですね
私がもうとんでもない生命体だと
自分だけ完璧だと思ってるんだと
ですから 例えばちっちゃな子供たちが
子供が一人がいて もう皆様
まあ私にしましょう 他の問題は来るんだからね
子供が私を見て  変な外人だとかね
お化けみたいやとかね
言われたとしましょう
だから私に言われちゃってもどうったことないんですけどね
もうもうしっかりしますからね
その時は で 落ち込むでしょうね
だから皆様にしたってもの
誰かキモいとかね 臭いとかね
言われちゃうとすぐ腹が立っちゃうんですよ
だからそういう時 自分の修行であると
ここで私は自分が完全であるという気持ちを持ってるんだと
これがあるんだから 今ちょっと嫌な気持ち感じているんだと
どう見たって自分もまあそこら辺のどこにもあるただのじじばばと何の変わりはないんだと
だからそこで落ち着きを
あ そうということで終わらなくちゃいけないんですね
あ そうですかねとかね
そういうふうな修行をしたら
この問題は解決します
だから この一般世界で言ってるね
ちゃんと挨拶しなさいとかね
おじきはただ行儀正しく
なんだらかんだら そんなことではもうどうったことない
毎日言われてるんだからね
よく声を高くして高くじゃなくて大きい
まあ聞こえるように喋る
喋りなさいとかね で 敬語使ってくださいとかね
そんなことで管理しても
どこまで規則守るんですかね
だってそれは国によって規則違いますからね
他の国では人と仲良くする方法と
日本と人と仲良くする方法
それぞれ同じじゃないんです
だって挨拶の仕方も違うでしょ
国が変わると そういうことだから
この俗世間の行儀作法リスト作ってね
百科事典みたいな膨大なものを作って
それを覚えて こんなできっこはないんです
だから 何でしたっけ？マンカインドイズボーントゥキルという言葉を覚えておいて
私はそう 悪人だと 本来も
だからそれに直せなくてはいけないんだと
で 直す方は他の人間なんですね
だから人間と接しなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間に接すると 自分を褒めてくれると
ああ この人は何か自分を立てて
何か自分の利益を考えているかもしれません
落ち着かなくちゃあかんやと
自分を貶したりすると
あ なるほど これで私のあの変な幻覚が消すつくところですから
消すすくようにしてしてあげましょうと
我こそ完璧 正しいやという気持ちはね
これはもうダメだと言ってるんだから
この人はね あんた大馬鹿者やと言ったら
ああ なるほど 本当のこと言ってくれるんだと
私は頭完璧いいと思っていたんだけど
でも違うんだと そういうふうに自分を戒めていくんです
だから それにまず人間関係が必要なんですね
森に隠れてできるわけじゃないんです
普通の社会で生きていると
いろんな人といろんな性格の人とね
会うんですよ これすごくありがたいんですよ
話が言ったら理解する人もいるし
一方的に喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
こちらの話は全く聞かない人もいるし
いくら言っても自分の意見変えない人間もいるし
何がしら人を馬鹿にしようという気持ちで言葉使う人もいるしね
なので行儀作法がだらしない人はいるし
食べ方すごいかっこ悪くて
もうダサいな ものすごくない食べ方良くない人を見ていろいろですよ
そこでこの自分の自我で見てるんですよ
例えば この人の箸の使い方はもうおかしいと思っちゃうと
自分の自我なんです 自分が完璧だと思ってるんです
そこで自分を戒めるんですね
私の己が完璧だという変な妄想で
病気な目で見ると この人の箸の使い方がおかしいんですよと
しかし その人は自分にできる範囲で頑張っているだけだと
年取った年寄りの方々はご飯食べたりするとね
こちらへこぼれたりする可能性あります
気持ち悪い このじじばばがね
もうかっこ悪い 思っちゃうと
これ正確なんですね 自分が恐ろしい存在だから
だから私は恐ろしい存在だから
このおじいさんの食べ方
気持ち悪いと思ったんだと
そこで自分を戒めて このおじいさんが自分にできる範囲で精一杯頑張っている
これおかしいと思うことは戒めましょう
という風に自分を戒めていることが今日の話のポイントなんです
それで終わりです はい
それからお休みになっても構いません
一応 はい 首狩り民族 英語ではキャニバリズムという首狩り民族のことを聞いて聞いているでしょうね
この風習は現在ではありませんね
キャニバリズムというのは
人間が人間の肉を食うことなんで
動物は同じ種類のことにはキャニバリズムとは言わないんだけど
生物学では言います しかし
この精神 相手を倒して自分が強くなる
これは脈々と続いています
だから正直になりましょう
我々は本当は首狩り民族なんです
共食い民族なんです それはやってないんですよ
やってないんだけど 人を倒して人と大喜利して
人に勝って俺が偉いと
って気持ちない？すーっとあるんです
あのサッカー試合はなんでしたっけ？いろんな国々がね
もうかなり能力のある一部だけ選んで
あのサッカー選手たちはもう
私もびっくりしました
人間にここまで能力 能力っていうのは肉体にあるんですね
とかね びっくりはしたんだけど
面白くはないんですね
ドイツはね たくさんあれゴールやっちゃったんだけどね
なんかちょっと で ネイマールがね
骨が折ってかわいそうなことになっちゃったんだからね
で これってキャニバリズムと似てない？あの首狩り民族のことご存知ですかね
あの あの あの 自分村である部族なんですけど
そこら辺に行って誰か人間見つけたら
この殺して首を切って
これはもうミイラにして自分の家でしきしと飾っておくんです
そうすると この殺された人のパワーが
エネルギーが自分に入ってくるんだと
自分がすごい人間になるんだと
そういうことで ある人の家の前でどれぐらい首をね
人間の首を刺しているのかということで
この人の偉大さ 偉大さがわかるんです
時代が変わってこれできなくなったんだけど
首狩り民族は未だにいるんです
今はやってないんです
しかし その人々はこんなことはしませんよと
まだまだ過剰なんですけど
で 我々文化人だと思っている人間はどうですかね
皆様方はとっても尊敬しているアメリカ人って何ですかね
国を潰して人を潰してみんなに悪口
馬鹿なことを言ったりして
自分たちが力強いという風に錯覚をさらにさらに起こすだけでしょうね
日本が突然 この集団的
なんだらかんだら なんだあれはと
他の国と一緒に戦争しようと
自分で一人でできんだからね
といったってアメリカだけなんですけどね
アメリカの軍隊は世界一強いんだからね
これでコソコソと便所掃除に一緒に行けば
まあ自分にも立場あるという考えでしょ
あれで日本は全然守られませんよ
ただ 首狩り民族の思考感情なんです
で 学校ででも スポーツの世界ででも
会社でも どこででも 人に勝って自分が強くなると
気持ちはもう延々と続いています
勝利とは成功した 人生とは同じ人間と競争して相手を倒して潰して自分が生き延びることです
人間の成功の定義はなんですかね
たくさんの人々を倒して潰してやることなんです
例えば アパレル作業を始めたある人が
自分でブランドネームを作って
どんどんいろんなところで店を開いて開いていって
他のアパレル作業の人々の場合は倒産しちゃって店じまいになってくる
本人が成功者と言うんですね
でしょ じゃあ携帯会社使いましょうかね NTT
ドコモとソフトバンクがありますね
NTTは初めからもう俺こそ偉いという感じでいるんだから
なかなか客がないんですね
そこでソフトバンクはいろんなごまかしからくりでやって
ものすごい金取り上げちゃいますけど
で 一番大きいキャリア会社になりますね
それで成功者と言うでしょ
ソフトバンクの社長も
そのためにはライバルの携帯会社と戦って
そこを潰さなくちゃあかんですね
だからそれは完璧に潰すことはもう法律的に不可能だからね
でもできることなら潰しちゃいますよ
NTTが倒産しましたと言ったら
もうソフトバンクは万々歳なんですよ
KDDIも倒産しましたと言ったら
ソフトバンクは万々歳なんです
それで成功したというでしょ
だから首狩り民族じゃないんですかね
我々その哲学で生きているでしょ
人のこの本音を隠しておくことがマナーであり
この本音をあらわにする
仏教は核廃棄物扱いです
だからそんなことを公で絶対言わない
ユニクロの社長やらソフトバンクやら
もうこれ首狩り民族やとかね
言ったらもうマナー違反でしょ
だから世の中でマナーっていうのは嘘を言えと
あなたって本当に優しい人間ですねとかね
嘘を言ってもらいたいんですね
あれはマナーなんですね
仏教では嘘をつくことはマナーじゃないんです
だから仏教という教えはみんな核廃棄物扱いですね
よくわかる現象なんですけど
これは皆様に対して言いますけどね
皆様方はまあ神社やら何でも手を合わせてかしわを打って
犬でも猫でも犬のフンでもね
ご利益あったら手を合わせるでしょ
しかし 南無妙法蓮華という場合は
仏壇さんに絶対手を合わせないんですね
そんなもんなんです 手を合わせるべきところなんですけど
犬猫にカエルさんに手を合わせて
キツネさんに手を合わせちゃってもね
もうただの迷信で何のご利益もないんだけど
はい 生命 人間を含む 含む
本能 本性 本質  これ仏教用語ですけど
日本語でもよく使っているんですね
本能とかね この本能があるんです
私たちに 前説明しましたからね
イントロダクションでわかりやすく
今はちょこっと深めに行くだけ
この本能っていうのは無明と渇愛なんです
アホなんです だから私が完璧や正しいやと思っているんです
この私がという主語が出たらもうアウトです
もう恐ろしい 殺し屋です
私がという主語が頭に入った時点で
そこで我々の本能 本能は本性は
あるいは本質は無明と渇愛です
また貪瞋痴とも言いますね
ロードドースもう それから自我があるという錯覚があるんですね
私がいるんだという錯覚
それは錯覚ですね 脳の錯覚です
終わりのない執着 満たされない気持ちあるでしょ
私たちはいくら執着しても終わりがないんですね
いつでももっと欲しい
もっと欲しいというね
気持ちがどうしてもある
それから何やっても満たされないんですね
だから恐ろしい人間になっちゃうんです
主観的な認識 理解 判断
行動 そこで我々は何を認識しても主観で認識する
自分勝手で 判断も自分勝手で
行動も自分勝手で だからあのオープニングスライドに入れたボーンとキルなんです
理性ではなく感情に支配されていること
これは本能ですよ 刺激に依存する刺激
のみを求める 人間 結局は大金持ちになりたいとかね
有名な知識人になりたいとかね
あんなのはあったっても
本当のところは刺激欲しいだけ
刺激欲しいだけ だから学校で勉強することより
悪い仲間と遊ぶことが刺激多いんだったら
それ選ぶんです また 腰抜けで学校でも勉強はしたくない
友達とも遊びたくない
友達も仲間に入れてくれない
それでゲームばっかりしてゲーム依存する
それから刺激を受ける
だから子供には言っちゃうと皆さん悪口を言うんだから
これは大人は同じことなんですよ
刺激多い方に行くんであって
あの 自分にとっていいことの方に行くわけじゃないんですね
例えば大学教授でもしっかりと研究して
かなり立派な研究を発表しましょうと頑張っているとしましょう
で そこから刺激を得ているんです
そこで悪い友達が出てきて
その先生をいろんなところに連れて行って
もう酒やらいろんな麻薬やらいろんなことを紹介してあげて
すぐ楽しくしてあげちゃうと
研究は後回しにしてこの世界に行っちゃうんです
そういう人間な人間というのは
大学の教授と言ったんだけどだけじゃなくてね
人間がそんなもんなんです
はい もう本能はわかりましたね
だから自分の気持ちを大事にしなさいと世の中言ってるでしょう
絶対してはいけません
本当は自分の気持ちはどんなでどうでもいいやと
やるべきことをやりますと思ったら
すごい人生楽なんです
それから一般的に言うと
自分に正直にとか 仏教でいう場合は別な意味です
ごまかすなよと 嘘を言うなよと
今 前 前のスライドで言ったのは
自分に正直であるならば
あのリストなんです しかし
世間でいう自分に正直っていうのはやってはいけません
とんでもないことになるんです
はい 経験から学ぶ 自我中心だけでは生き生き生きられない
他を潰すために 倒すためにも協力が必要です
でしょ しかし これは本能ではありません
自分一人で人を倒すことができればやっちゃいます
できない場合は誰か誰か仲間頼むんですよ
経験を感情にあ ちょっと間違ってます
経験を感情の上にかぶるだけです
それで感情が我こそは正しいという殺し屋なんですね
しかし うまくいかない
仲良くしなくちゃいけない
お母さんに暴言吐いただけで
お母さん何でもやってくれるわけじゃないんですね
だからお母さんに優しい言葉を語る
お父さんにおかてこの野郎
馬鹿野郎 お金くれと言ってもくれない
だからお父さん お願いしますからね
なんとかという風にちょっとごまかすんですね
ゴマをすっちゃうんですね
でお父さんからお金をもらうとかね
そういうふうに我々はいろんな行儀作法
礼儀作法をやってます
うまくいくために これは世間では道徳とかね
礼儀作法とかねと言ってます
言葉遣いとかね いろんなことを言ってます
しかし 私が言いたいのは
あの醜い本能の上に この礼儀作法というのは被ってるだけ
あの接着剤ででもつけてないんです
ガラスの丸いガラスの上になんかカステラみたいなものを入れたらすぐ外れますからね
ガラスの玉だったら もう接着剤でない限りは
限りはカスラなんかはつけられないでしょう
止めるところないんです
だから我々の脳がもう完璧な悪で
上に道徳は乗せてますけど
ちょっとしたことで滑るんです
ちょっと風が吹いたら終わりです
だからどんな人間でも普通は大人しいんですよ
でも ちょっと隣の人がね
あの 何といいますか くしゃみしただけでも
何やったらこの野郎とぶん殴る可能性あります
わからない とても危ない
そこで皆様が今日理解してほしいのは
この私たち世界中 人間が行儀作法
礼儀作法 あれやこれやとかね
宗教も教えている 道徳やらね
いろんなゴミを守ってますよ
でもあれは被ってるだけ
本能の上で上乗せしているだけ
ちょっと揺らいだら落ちる
だからニュースなんか見ると
すごい立派な人々も痴漢したり捕まったとかあるでしょ
簡単に合わせます 周りと仲良くしなくてはいけないという条件にはめられた時でさえ
本能と建前の対立で葛藤で苦しむんです
そこで私は仲良くしなくちゃ
しっかり行儀作法を守らなくてはとかね
頑張ってるでしょ その時でも心の中で葛藤があるんです
気持ちよくやってるわけじゃないんです
会社の社長と喋っているときは
とってもとても行儀作法よくてね
言葉は丁寧に使ってね
でも疲れます 心の中は葛藤があるんです
本能と上乗せした道徳の間で葛藤が起こるんです
調和を保つことは至難の業です
決して楽じゃないんです
クジラは歩けない どんな意味ですかね
それは でも私もこれでも結構考えますよ
結構考えて だからクジラ歩けないってことは
それ何が言いたいかというとね
あんた方 人間たちにはね
仲良くすることはできませんと
だってクジラ歩けないでしょ
別にクジラがちっぽけな魚でもなんでもないんです
巨大な哺乳類生物ですよ
地球上の一番大きい立派な存在ですけど
歩けないんです 心は仲良くし
仲良くしないように 仲良くすることができないように設定されています
説明しましたね 最初は仲良くしないように
仲良くできないように
この 2つポイントなんです
仲良くしないように 仲良くできないようにできています
仲良くするよりは 喧嘩した方が
相手に攻撃した方が 相手を見下した方が
相手を打ち破った方が楽です
じゃあ本能で聞いてみてください
建前ではなくて 自分の本音で
楽でしょう 仲良くするのは楽じゃないでしょう
他人を認めること 許すこと
理解すること 哀れむことなどは相当無理をしなくてはいけないんです
本当にみんな無理をしていますよ
人を助けてあげるとか
人を哀れむとかね 人のことを認めるとかね
ものすごい無理をしているんです
はい 次 またとんでもないタイトルで
犬に仏性はありますか？と
大乗仏教では本来仏性がありという概念があります
大乗仏教ではね すべての森羅万象に本来仏性ありというふうに言っているんです
皆もともと善人だ 覚者と言うんですかね
これは 覚者だ と理解するとおかしい話になります
これで大乗仏教はね 時々立派な方々はわけのわからない
あと私はクジラが歩けないような言葉を使いますよ
仏教の知識があったら
あんなふうなフレーズというのはいくらでも作れます
で コピーライトになったら方が私はもっと金儲かるだろうと思いますけどね
まあ誰も買ってくれません
とにかくいろんなフレーズ言えます
だから 実相仏性というすべてのものごとに仏性ありという
これ大乗仏教ではね あれ
大乗般若心経にある般若心経じゃなくて
涅槃経にある言葉ですけどもね
あってね これがそれからあの頭のあんまり完璧ではないお坊さんたちが
まあみんな本来悟っているんだ
あれやこれやとか言うんですね
あれ 日本ではえらい勘違いで
これ道元さんも困ったんですね
すべて本来悟っているというならば
なんであなた方も私も修行しているんですかと
修行する必要ないでしょうにと
悟ってるんだから だからそこを調べるために中国に行って修行して
禅宗で曹洞禅宗 曹洞宗は作ったんですね
道元禅師がその答え 何か見つかったようで見つかってないようで
よくわからない状態なんですね
私の個人的な アイディアで言うならば
あまり見つかってない
なんとなく なんとなくちょっと近寄っただけで答えは見つかってないんです
で そこでこの本当はみんなに仏性は仏性はあるんだという話で
みんな悟っている完璧な連中やとね
言ってるわけじゃないんです
これから説明します 無明と渇愛という基礎があり
貪瞋痴に支配されている
人間というのは 経験上得た優しさ
共存 助け合いなどの考えを心に上乗せています
人間ならそんなもんなんですよ
無知で無知が基礎 貪瞋痴が基礎
だからってみんな悪をやっているわけじゃないんです
ボーンとキルなんですけど
誰も殺してないんです
稀な人間以外は ほとんどの人々はもう殺してないんです
それで あの本来の極悪の心の上に
まあ優しさ 思いやり 助け合い
共存 神様仏様を思いじることとかね
親を親孝行することとかね
いろんなものを上乗せするんですね
かぶっておくんですね
大体どんな人間もそんなもんなんです
それで 心の中に常に葛藤があります
それだけじゃなくて ぐちゃぐちゃ
ぐちゃぐちゃ 誰だって葛藤で生きているんです
天使と悪魔の戦いはずっと心の中にあるんです
しかし 天使は本来本性じゃなくて
悪魔が本性な本性なんです
天使は上に乗っているだけで
すぐ滑ってしまいます
すぐ滑るんです 悪魔が本能なんです
だから そういう物語もありますから
頭の中でずっと葛藤があるんですよね
善と悪の すべての生命の心はこのような状態で働いています
これで犬猫を見ても同じ働き
ライオン トラ シカ 馬を見ても同じ働き
心は みんな戦ってます
セントアクト 良い人 悪い人
優れた人などの区別は本質から考えると成り立たない
だから大乗仏教で この言葉を最初に書いた人が言いたかったのは
あんた善人だ あんた悪人だ
あんた悟っている そんなことは言えませんよと
あんた修行を進んでいるんだとかね
見てみればみんな同じこっちゃよと
だから私も皆様の本性というのは極悪やと言ったでしょう
本当に悪人と言える？言えない
皆様は誰一人も悪人じゃないんです
では善人？これもちょっと言いづらいでしょう
だから何者かと言えない状態
いわゆる基本的な状態である
生命の という意味で仏性という言葉を使っているんです
だからこの単語は間違って使ったんだけど
本人たちが言いたかったのは同じことなんです
なぜならば この自然の法則
心の法則にも呪いと言っちゃったんだから
あの人々は 大乗の人々は
だから言語の使い方は下手なんですね
だからこの この竜樹からもなく
やっぱり言葉使いの場合はちょっといろいろ失敗があったんですね
これは般若心経なんか読んでみたら
もう言語はわかってないと言えるぐらいアホなんですね
ああいうふうに言葉を使っちゃうと
何言ってるかと やっぱりもう書いた本人もわからない矛盾だらけになるんです
この言語の言葉の使い方でちょっと誤解するようになっただけで
仏性というのは親鸞晩年の常にある姿なんです
だからそれわかってるかないか知りたくて
ある禅師が 弟子に聞くんですね
弟子がすべてのものに仏性ありがと
ああそう では犬に仏性ある？と聞いたんです
これ公案なんです 一切衆生は同じ流れに流されています
この状態は怪しげな仏性という言葉で表現されています
犬とは人間 公案の答え出します
これ私の答え持っていって
それのお坊さんたちに言って
ちょっと覚悟をつけてください
だいたいお坊さんたちも答え知らないんです
犬とは人間が考える差別用語なので
この公案にはYESもNOもありません
犬に仏性あると言えない
犬といったら差別用語なんです
仏教の立場から考えていないんです
逆に見れば 一切の生命の本来の姿だから
なぜ犬と区別する必要あるんですかね
だから答えは犬って何ですかねと
です 先生 私に犬を教えてあげてくださいと
それで仏性あるかないかわかりますよ
とは答えなんですから
こういう風な公案にはYESもNOもないんです
だから日本人が頭打ちに乗り上がっちゃって
曖昧中途半端ではっきりしないでしょ
人生はYESも言わないでノーも言わないで
あんなのはとんでもないんです
これはもう仏教の世界にあるかなりレベル高い話なんです
イエスノーない世界は
皆様方 イエスとノーがなくなっちゃって生きていられませんよ
次のポイントは区別と同一
生命はみな個人です 互いに似ているところはあっても
同一同等にはなりません
みんな個人です あの人と同じということにはなりません
覚えておいてほしいんです
その他の表現も同じです
現象も同じです その他の現象といってもね
まあそれは他の現象でもね
まあもともと見ると 例えばこの椅子と皆様方座っている椅子が同じ
同じじゃない では皆様方
この列に座っているでしょ
全部椅子が同じ なんか同じように見えるだけで別々なんです
だからこのホールの皆様方
座っている椅子を見てください
できるだけ同じくなろうと作って頑張ってますけど
なれません 別々な椅子なんです
なのになんか似ているような
色は似ているとかね 機能は似ているとかね
形状が似ているとかね
あるかもしれません 座るところの背もたれ
背もたれのね プロポーションが同じやとかね
しかし似ていないんです
個別なんです 一つの木の葉を調べても
1枚1枚違います 私たちは同じやと思っちゃうでしょ
ただ バラのするがり バラするですからね
これはバラの葉 バラの葉
バラの葉とかね まとめちゃいますけど
本当はそうじゃないんですね
1枚1枚違います  1枚1枚に個性があるんです
頭でこの差を理解できないので
葉はすべて同じだとまとめてしまいます
だから我々 そんな頭が良くないんだから
どんなバラの花の種類が変わっても
葉を見たら これはバラの葉の葉であるとまとめちゃいますね
無知度が高い場合は一則一切読めますね
とまとめることもできます
この一則一切というのは
大乗のお坊さんたちはすごく誇らしげに言うフレーズなんです
これはヒンドゥー教のパクリなんです
だから私がこれをもうくたっと言ってるんです
無知度が高すぎやと だってこういう例で考えてください
大きいブナの木がありますね
葉っぱ何枚ある？わからないでしょ
じゃあ  10万枚ぐらいあるとしましょう
大きい木だからね それ私が言いたいのは
この10万枚の葉っぱは 1枚1枚違うんだと
葉はちょっと人間みたいな人格を与えれば
1枚1枚の葉は個人なんですね
自分のプライバシーを持ってるんです
1枚の葉さんは隣の葉
私は何々さんで あなたはなになにさんやと
しかしそれって人間の頭では理解できんでしょ
だって人間を見てみれば同じだから
だから世間すべて一つであると言ったら相当バカなんです
個別を無視しているんです
区別から普遍性を発見する
我々の頭が悪いかもしれませんだけど
といったっても ある程度で頭がいいでしょう
ある程度で このある程度で十分です
このある程度で物事を区別を知ってほしい
自分の家族にいるみんな
それぞれのプライバシーを持っている
個性を持っている 人権を持っている
別々人間であると 家族だから皆同じやという
あんな無知な話しないでください
会社の仲間は会社だからみんな同じやと
そんなバカなことを言わないでください
はい そういう風に みんな個性がある
別々な別々なものと見てから
区別を認めて それから調べて共通するところを発見する
家族はみんなそれぞれ違うんだけど
みんな同じご飯を食べているとかね
この 3人は同じ両親の子供であると
そういうふうに共通性
名前は同じやとかね 次にそれを見つかった
発見しなくちゃいけない
それから現象を作り出す法則を発見する
だから なんでこうなるのかと
なんで植物は一つはそれで
一つはものすごい幹が大きくて
一つは細い幹でいろんなでしょ
葉っぱの形はそれぞれ違うでしょ
花の形はそれぞれ違うでしょ
鳥たち見たっても 一羽一羽本当に違うでしょ
これ種類によってまた違うでしょ
なんだよ これはと調べてほしい
はい それは科学の世界ですから
やらなくてもいいんです
やっている人々はいるんです
そこでこの 鳥の生物学者と昆虫の生物学者とかね
植物の生物学者とか それから植物の中での一部を研究するとか
ものを研究者とか いろいろいるんですね
で 昆虫に至っても すべての昆虫ではなくて
一部だけ選んでやっている人々がいてね
そういう人々は区別を見て
それから共通性を発見するんです
例えば たくさんの生命体は昆虫であるというためには
何か共通したものがなければね
生き物と植物を区別するためには何か必要ですね
生き物 植物は自分で栄養を作るんですね
生命は外から栄養を取らなくちゃいけない
はい そこでクロロフィルというものがあって
太陽から合成しますね
栄養は それは植物と言うんです
葉っぱ違うかもしれません
水の中に住んでいる植物かもしれません
同じ仕事をやっています
はい 科学世界ではこれをやっていますから
皆様方は困らなくても結構です
一個一個違ったこの現象の世界でサクションが発見された普遍的な真理は無常苦無我なんです
科学者と違って て さらに進んでみたんです
昆虫には足が 4本あるんだよ
6本あるんだよ そこで止まってないんです
生老病死やと さらに進んだら
無常苦無我であると それが普遍的な真理なんです
一色一色一切ではありません
だから一色一切はヒンドゥ教でもありますけど
あれはもう仏教は使ってはいけません
すべては無常苦無我であると
はい 区別から差別へということを勉強しましょう
区別に気づいたとしましょう
例えば 自分がある人と会う
会ったらこの人はもう
例えば背が私の腰のあたりでしかない
年は私と同じ 背の高さが私の腰あたりで
まあ 2メートルもならん程度で
そこで私はすぐ区別を見つかるでしょう
あ この人の背が低いと見つかったとしましょう
それにそれは感情で理解すると差別です
そこで私は自分の背の高さが完璧だと思って
思う 感情で 気持ちで  2メートルでもなくて
1メートルちょっと 20 センチ程度でね
こうやってこの人の背が低く
と思っちゃったら 私はこの人差別しているんです
だから自分の尺度で自分が完璧という尺度で
あなた背が低いねとか言ったら差別なんです
逆にあなた身長はどれぐらい？なるほど
と言っちゃえば 別にとったことないんです
あの人は背が高いというのはただの区別ですね
そこに欲 怒り 憎しみ 恨み
無知 慢などの感情が割り込むと差別です
だから欲であの人の背が高いというと差別なんです
怒りであなたの背がもう高くないでしょうと言ったら
すぐ差別なんです だから区別に感情が入っちゃうと差別なんです
とても危険です 人は感情に支配されているので
発見するすべての区別は差別になってしまうんです
そこで我々は感情に支配されているでしょう
だから区別見えますよ
見えるんだけど すべて差別になるんです
このホールに来るときでも
人によって ああ 結構立派なホールだな
ボロクソホールだなとかね
古いホールだなとかね
もうなんでこんなちょっと離れたところにあるんだなとか
いろいろすべて差別になっちゃうんです
それで区別か差別か 以下の単語を読んでみましょう
これからテスト出します
ゴールド アイアン ディグ
意味がわからないんだったら
一応日本語で書きました
ゴールドは日本語で言わなくてもわかってるでしょ
はい 覚えた  3種類の物質だと思えないでしょ
あ なんだ これ  3種類の物質ですよと思った？思ってない
ゴールドといえば結構価値があって
鉄で言えばまあたまたま役に立つんであって
土 なんだこれはと でしょ？もう差別なんです
もうやられちゃったんです
差別してしまったんです
人は違いを見つけて差別するんです
科学者になりません しかし
覚えてください 線は引いてある文章です
差別するとは罪を犯すことです
だから前のゴールドアイアンと言っただけでも
もう心が汚れているんです
罪を犯っているんです
次のテーマに行きます
差別世界 何を考えても差別することではあると
宗教は断言的に差別思考で成り立った教えです
政治 経済 哲学 科学などは差別感情がなく発展させることはできます
しかし やってないのです
政治論は差別なくできますけど
差別でやってるんです
科学者の中でも差別主義があるんです
科学には差別関係ないんですよ
だって差を知ることが科学
科学だから差を知って共通性発見する
それは科学なんです でも差別主義主義なんです
それでも 人間が食文化に就いても差別感情を抱いているんです
何を言おうかというと
食べることだってどんな人間でも食べてるでしょうに
どんな人間食べたってもね
小麦粉やご飯やらチキンやら野菜やらね
食べるものも似てるでしょうに
世界中 インド人が草食べて日本人がキャベツ食べてるわけじゃないでしょうに
日本人もキャベツ食べてる
インド人もキャベツ食べてます
日本人もニンジン食べてる
インド人もニンジン食べてます
同じものでしょ 食べてるのはみんな人間が
世界中 しかし 食文化になってくると
まあ差別はありゃしないぐらい差別
すごい差別 ちょっと宗教の説明に入ります
ウパニシャッドにある師匠たちの教えは
森羅万象のすべてが神話という梵天から現れたということです
あのヒンドゥー教でもバラモン教でもないんだけど
ウパニシャッド哲学というインドにありまして
あれ連中は一応哲学者と言うんですけどね
彼らが言うのは すべてのものはある一個の魂から現れたんだと
これは真我とも言うし
梵我とも言うし 梵天とも言います
この一個の魂がバラバラになっちゃって
森羅万象が現れている
だから薔薇の植物も稲も違うんだけど
同じなんです 真我が同じものなんです
もともとは だから私は厳格で
薔薇は薔薇で 稲は稲でしょうに
薔薇は食べられませんし
稲は食べられますよと
米になったらとか区別するんです
これはマーヤイリュージョンと言うんです
ウパニシャッドでは それで薔薇も私の体も犬も稲も米もご飯も何でもかんでも同じものです
私とあなたは同じです
タットマシという言葉で表現しているんですね
だからこの一族一切という言葉が出たんです
世は無数の互い違い現象であるように見えるが
あるように見えるが 点は要らんだけど
それは人の幻覚です 真理を知る人はすべてが我であるとわかるんです
これはヒンドゥー教で仏教ではありません
だからよく皆様理解するでしょうと思いますけど
あの 私たちには全部別々に見えるんだけど
これは私のイリュージョンであって
本当は我ですと 魂ですと言うんですね
ウパニシャッドでは これは差別を否定する思考ですが
ですから ウパニシャッド哲学は差別を否定しているんです
例えば このペットボトルとこのマウスは
私たちバカどもたちには別々でしょ
ペットボトルをいくら動かしたっても
パソコンは動いてくれませんだからね
これはイリュージョンであって
ウパニシャッド哲学では
これは同一の同じものなんです
神様の魂なんです だから差別できないんです
犬見たらこの犬めとは言えないんです
自分と同じなんです バラモン教もヒンドゥ教も差別思考で凍り固まっています
結局は人間が人間ですよ
頭で知識であんなくだらない哲学言っても
本来はボーントゥキルなんです
だからインドほど差別がある世界はないと言えるぐらい差別はあります
すごいんです ひどいんです
アメリカヨーロッパほどはないかもしれませんだけど
ありますよ イギリス人なんか我々はもうもう名前聞いただけで気持ち悪くなるくらい差別主義者ですからね
誰だって同じこっちゃですよ
結局は差別主義者なんです
だから私は文句言いたいの
ヒンドゥー教の人々に
あなた方はこういう哲学でしょうにと
ウパニシャッド仙人たちが仙人と言うんですよ
ウパニシャッドの仙人たちがこれ言ってるのに
なんでカースト制度あるんですかと
なんで人を差別するんですかと
しかし ヒンドゥー教は
それからバラモン教は
バラモン教っていうのは古い名前で
ヒンドゥー教というのは同じ宗教につけた新しい名前で
差別でなければ成り立ちません
カースト制度でなければ成り立ちません
ですから お釈迦様はインドで生まれてインドで説法したんだから
この差別についてものすごく批判するんです
厳しく差別思考を批判します
植物 生物の間では差異は明確ですが
人間同士では何の差も成り立たないのだと説かれています
スッタニパータ 皆様も日本語で読まれていると思います
ワサラス経典という経典があります
そこは長い長い経典で
植物見なさいよと 互い違いますよと
動物見なさいよと みんなそれぞれ違いますよと
魚見なさい 鳥たち見なさいよと
それぞれ違いますよと
しかし 人間見たら何が違うのかと
だから面白くて お釈迦様は生物学的に人間は一緒であると言っているんです
人間は生命として一種であることを強調します
生物学的に一種ですが
人間は平等であるとも説かれないんです
だから科学的に言えば
人間というのはホモ・サピエンスなんですね
ホモ・サピエンスなんですけど
みんな同じ一緒ということも言わないんです
差があるんだと 差別はダメだけなんですね
行為によって人の差が成り立たすのだと明言します
人間の場合は行為だよと
バラモン人であろうが
泥棒やったら強盗やと
強盗やったら泥棒やと
バラモン人でも人を殺したら殺人やと
シュードラカーストの人でも同じこっちゃよと
いろんな経典で王様たちにも対話しながらそれ話すんです
そこでこのある王家の人なんですけど
あの この人はお釈迦様にね
まあではないんですけど
このバラモン人が一番立派なカーストであると
他のカーストはみんな卑しいよと
ずっと言ってますよと
そしたらあれはただの音やと
ジェストノイズグロース
何の関係もないと仏教側は言うんです
ジェストノイス うるさいだけやと
そこでこの人は王様ですから
聞くんです ではあなたに聞きます
もしバラモン人が朝早く起きて
一生懸命仕事をして 丁寧に真面目に
夜遅くまで頑張って仕事をすると豊かになる
ならないもなる ではシュードラカーストの人が
一生懸命朝早く起きて
夜遅くまで頑張って無駄遣いもしないで
まあ商売やったり いろんなことをやったら豊かになる
ならないなる だからカーストって何ですか？と
そこで次のポイント省略します
バラモン人がいいところです
ワイシュヤカーストの人がいいところです
シャトリアカーストの人がいいところです
シュードラカーストの人がいいところですと
そうするとあなたはね
あ この人はバラモンカーストで一番トップのカーストだから
その人とはね いえいえ
違います 捕まりますよと
だったらカーストの差が何なのかと
カーストの差って何なのかと
で 逆に聞く まあ道徳的に人が殺傷しないで
嘘を言わないで 盗みをしないで
邪な行為をしないでとか
うんぬんと道徳がありますね
道徳を守っている その人は死ぬ
死ぬ 死んだら天国 あんた何？カーストと聞く
聞かないでしょ 良いことをしたら天国に行くと
それはまあ 推測的に喋らなくちゃいけないんだけど
例えば ある人がもうありったけの悪いことをする
人殺しから女を犯すことやら何でも
しかしバラモン人です
それで死んじゃったら
あ あんたバラモン人だから天国に行ってくださいと
ありえますかと ありえないんだと
だからあいつらのただうるさいだけだと
気にすることはないんだと
これは仏教の結論なんです
で そういう風に経典にはあるんだけど
本当はバラモン人っていうのはもっと気持ち悪いんです
このバラモン人から書くテキストにあるんです
バラモン人が人を殺しても
女を犯しても罪にならないんだと
しかし 低いカーストの人はバラモン人をいじめたり殴ったりするともう重罪になるんだと
そこまでテキストはあるんです
努力するものは カーストは何であろうとも豊かになります
人を殺したり強盗したりする人は
カーストと関係なく裁かれます
出家して心を清らかにする修行するものは
カーストと関係なく尊敬されます
王様に聞いたんです 王様
バラモンの人が出家して真面目に戒律を守って修行すると
あんたどうする？尊敬しますと
ではシュードラ いわゆる一番低いカーストの人
シュードラの人が出家して
しっかり戒律を守って修行して
心を清らかな修行を あんたどうする？私はちゃんと尊敬してお布施あげますと
だったらカースト関係ないだろうにと
人間はこうでしょうにという結論なんです
すぐに一神教の世界についても一言葉言わないと
で 絶対的神 唯一の神を
神がたくさんいるので
各宗教の人々は互いに争います
だから一神教っていうのは
絶対的神がすべて創ったっていう話でしょ
だったら喧嘩する必要はないんですよ
全部神が作ったんだからね
で この連中結婚するんです
おかしいことは 絶対的神っていうのは何人もいるんです
イエホワもいるし アッラーもいるし
またいるんでしたっけ？アホロマスもいるしね
インドにもいるし まあいるはいる
結構 互いに争います 罵ります
殺し合いします 本当に戦争までするんだから
神は全知全能で無限の愛がある
森羅万象を創造したのです
これはどんな一神教でも言っていること
それではこの世のすべては神の作品です
でしょ 神が創ってないものは何もないんだから
しかし 一神教徒には異端者も存在するんですね
どういうこと これは 仏像を壊すべきとかね
仏教徒は殺すべきとか
キリスト教もイスラム教も結構仏教の人々を殺してやるって頑張ってますけどね
私が言いたいの あんた方は神を侮辱しているんじゃないんですかと
だって私も作ったのは神でしょうに
私にこの知識を与えたのは神でしょうに
私にこの能力を与えたのは神でしょうに
だから神がこの生き方を期待しているんです
だから理性で使えば 神の概念もまんざら悪くないんです
理性使えば 私はそれはキリスト教の人々にも
イスラム教の人々にも
チャンスがあったら教えてあげているんです
あんた方は理性使ってくださいと
アリ一匹でも神の大事な作品だよと
だから神を愛するならば
神を恐れるならば アリ一匹に対しても神の作品だからという気持ちを作ってくださいよと
俺が潰してやる 殺してやる
食ってやるとかね どういうことかと
そういう気持ちだったら
あんた方は本当に神のことを信仰していると思いますよと
でなきゃどうぞ地獄に行ってください話にするんです
あんた方は冒涜しているんだと
そういうことで あの そういう理論もそうなんですけど
やっぱり人間がボーンとキルなんです
本性は これではうまくいかないんだけど
やっぱり殺します 一神教思想は人を差別するために使用されています
だから我は本当の神を信じている
この人々は本当の神を信じていない
初めから一神教は唯一神は己でありって
他の神を信じるなよと書いてますからね
その時点でこいつは大馬鹿者なんです
唯一神は自分だけだったら
他の神はいないでしょうに
とんでもないアホなんですけど
聖書を書いたのはね で
ユダヤ教から始めたでしょ
ユダヤ教はユダヤ人が選民たちで
他はどうでもいいです
差別でしょう 仏教の世界観
区別を知り尽くして差別をなくす
では 仏教の教えに入りましょう
他をけなすものは仏教徒ではありません
仏教は厳しいんです 他を殺すところじゃなくて
けなすものは だって仏教っていうのは本来ボーンとキルって状態を直せなく直すことだから
時間を潰すことだからね
そこでカンティーパラマンタポーティティッカ
忍耐と耐え忍ぶことは最高の修行であると
だからそれだけで仏教は宗教じゃないとわかるでしょう
修行っていろいろあるでしょ
お釈迦様っていうのは忍耐
耐え忍ぶこと それが修行ですよと
ただの修行じゃなくて最高
直接自我を潰すんだからね
世界の差別的な態度 非難
侮辱に対して攻撃をしないことですね
解説すると 世界に非難されても
侮辱されてもニコッといる
私は最初に説明してしまったの
やり方 気にしないで耐える
お前バカだ あれやこれやと言われたって
まあ別に手を振ってバイバイとか気にしないでいる
これは最高の修行なんです
ナヒパッバジトーパルーパガーティサマノーホーティパランリヒテヤントー
出家は他を殺さない 他に害を与えるものは武士仏弟子ではありませんと
どれほど厳しいかとわかりますかね
こんな宗教争い もう人に害を与えたらもう仏弟子失格なんです
洗脳 いわゆる本能を破ることは修行です
心は差別するように洗脳されていますね
感情に支配されているので
違いを発見するたびに差別感情を抱く
だから仏教も違いを発見しなさいと言っているんです
で 発見したら差別するんだから困ったもんです
危険なのは この世で似ているもの
同一のものはほとんど存在しません
これ危険です なぜ危険かというと
差別見たらじゃなくて
区別を見つけたら差別
区別を見つけたら差別だから
だから危険でしょ すべて違うんだから
だから無量の罪を犯してるんですよ
だってこのコード見ていくと
このコードとこのコード違うでしょ
何見ても区別なんです
それで差別しちゃうと
特にコードの場合は差別しませんよ
このコードは太いなのは線は 4本あるからとかね
このコードは細いなのはマイクロフォンコードだからとかね
その時は区別で罪を犯してないんです
人間を見ると違う 生命を見ると違う
あの犬は可愛い この犬はちょっと醜い
もうできているんです
あの人はもう痩せすぎ
あれ これはとか 生命見るともう差別
ということは 認識するたびに差別感情を抱く恐れがあるんです
差別は罪です 冗談じゃないんです
だから仏道は他を侮辱しないことなんです
忍耐なんです 共食い人生を脱出するんです
共食い感情は本能です
それを破る努力を修行です
何があっても 何が起きても
差別感情を抱かないように励む
慈しみで生きることですね
だから慈しみっていうのは
この安っぽい話じゃないんです
無理にでも慈しみを育てるんです
自分を馬鹿にした人にも
この人は幸せでありますように
もう怒ってはならんとかね
怒ったら私の負けやと
私の自我やと 私の錯覚やと
私は恐ろしい人間やと
バーンと蹴りやと だからいいんじゃないか
私を馬鹿にしたということは
すごいかっこいいんだと
宝物やと 馬鹿にされたら
だって自分で修行できるんだから
だから仏教的に見ると
人に馬鹿にされること
人に批判されること 人に差別されることっていうのはすごい宝物です
すごい宝物です 成長します
自分は はい これは楽な修行ではありません
それでもね 楽じゃないんです
自分の感情と戦わなくてはならないのです
感情の制御は難しいです
感情を理性に置き換えなくてはならないんです
だから難しいんだから
やり方あるんです これからやり方に行きますが
時間になってますから
そこら辺で講演やめてもよろしいと思います
何時まででしたっけ？ 9時までです
9時までです  区別は知識です
あの笹と竹の差を知ることは知識でしょ？だって区別でしょ
同じ植物系なんですけどね
うどんと醤油は食料ですね
同一だと思ってしまえば
うどんの代わりにね 醤油一瓶飲んで飲んで良いことではありませんね
だから一食一菜は危険です
やめてください だって醤油って食料でしょ？うどんも
じゃああんたうどん食べて
私は醤油飲みますと 一食一菜やと
頑張ってください だからもう頭悪い連中は格好つけて余計なことを言ったらあかんですよ
一食一菜というのはそういう世界なんです
やっぱり区別が必要です
うどんはうどんで 醤油は醤油です
それでうどん食べるというか
ちょっと味が足らないんだったら
ちょびっと醤油をかけるだけ
ちょびっと それでうまくいきます
それって知識です 観察瞑想実践では
まずこの区別能力が現れます
皆様方ご存知だろうと思いますけど
仏教は観察するという瞑想を指導しているんですね
初期仏教は これで何が得られるかというと
区別能力を得られます
区別は知識です だからお釈迦様のヴィパッサナー瞑想すると
すごい頭が良くなりますよ
神秘体験 超能力を目指して行う瞑想は仏道ではありません
私の悩みは 文句はそれなんです
私のところにヴィパッサナー実践する方々いるんだけど
みんななんか神秘体験欲しいんですね
超能力欲しいんですね
だったらダッボハーブでも吸っちゃえばいいんじゃないんですかね
そんなお金もかからないんで
3千円だそうです だってね
宿泊瞑想会でもね  3日
4日って結構金かかるでしょ
それでみんな邪道やってるんだから成長しないんですよ
今日でもお願いしますから
この区別能力を育てるんです
区別とは知識なんです
ご飯を食べる時も 一口ごとに差を知ることは区別能力です
だから私は最近それをあえて言ってるんですよ
ご飯食べる時 瞑想してくださいと
一口をご飯口に入れて
噛む 噛む 噛む 味わう 噛む
噛む 味わう 飲み込む それからまた実況中継で
次のご飯を取って運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 入れる それから箸を戻して
実況中継で戻す 戻す それから噛む
噛む 噛む 味わう 噛む 噛む
味わう 飲み込む そうすると同じご飯であっても
一口一口味が違う 違う品物やと
壮大な区別能力が生まれてくるんです
これでパクパクと蛇みたいに飲み込んだらね
もうバカで終わっちゃいますよ
バカで始めてバカで終わるんです
仏道の道はバカで始めて
知恵の完成さで終わるんです
区別能力から知恵へ 一個一個の現象は互い違いと知ることができれば
桁違いの知識人になります
この科学博士とかね 工学博士とか
世の中でいくらでも知識人がいますよ
でも私たちはただ ただのジジイなんですけど
人生として日常のことについての能力はないんですね
何も気にしない さっさと解決する能力っていうのはね
ですから この桁違いの知識人になります
あの汚れた世界の知識も大丈夫ですよ
例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想で区別能力が上がったら
それから英語を勉強してみてください
さっと入るんです フランス語を勉強してみてください
さっと心に入るんです
何のこともないんです
もう脳が区別能力を理解できるようにまとめようとするのは馬鹿です
はい これは現実的に不可能ですね
皆 一部のことに対して専門家
プロになるんです 世の中にある
例えば自分の弁当にあるご飯がね
例えば八 十回で食べるぐらいの量でしょ
これ十回に食べると 一回一回違うんだと理解すると
世の中はね ブドウを食べるたびに違うでしょ
リンゴを食べるたびに
その日のリンゴ違うでしょ
もう落ち着かなくなっちゃうんですよ
どこまで知っていいのかいと
だから これは無量無限にあるんだから
すべて知る必要はないんです
だから世の中にプロがいるんです
医学は 医者はすべて知らないんです
泌尿科はそこしか知らない
心臓外科は心臓のことしか知らない
脳の外科は脳のことしか知らない
外科は切ることしか知らない
内科は別なことを知ってますけど
切ることはできないとかね
みんな一部のプロなんです
しょうがないんです そんなに脳はでっかくはないんです
それは構わない 全然構わない
自分にできることを真面目にできればいいでしょう
陶器で作ることをできる人は
そちらにプロになればいいんです
絵を描く人はそれだけで十分プロになってくださいと
区別すればプロになるんです
土のこと 科学っていうのは土のことですね
いわゆる俗世間のこと
土のことを知っても 人格向上も心清らかになることも
煩悩が根絶して解脱に達することもありません
だからご苦労ですよ あんまり何の結果もないんですね
例えば 化学を一生学んだからといって
人間はそのまんま進化していない
猿のままですね だからかわいそうですね
苦労しているのに かえって煩悩が強化する
例えば 立派な画家になりたいと
朝から晩まで訓練して訓練して
区別し尽くして 絵画の世界
ものすごい見事なプロになったとしましょう
あれってすごい煩悩でしょ
私は日本一有名な画家であると
外国でも名前を知られていると
画家であると 煩悩です
死後は怖いんです 釈尊は五取蘊を観察しなさいとか
だから釈尊がね こんな面倒くさいことをやらなくて簡単だよと
五取蘊 体を構成しているルーパ
ウェーダナ サンニャー
サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナ
これだけ調べてください
至って簡単です 私はいつでもそれ説明しますからね
今日は説明しません 要するに
生きることは何かと調べましょうよと
お釈迦様は本当に小さな
やりやすい完了できる宿題を与えているんです
肉体のことを調べなさい
感覚のことを調べなさい
自分の感情のことを調べなさい
自分の思考概念を調べなさい
終わりですと あなた全部知ってますよと
区別能力が現れます どの時は
一切の生命は五蘊でできていること
因縁の組み合わせで 組み合わせと煩悩の働きによって
一人一人の生命は互い違い個であることも発見します
それです ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやる人は
自分の体を瞑想する そうすると
すべての生命は同じこっちゃやと
五蘊やと しかし個人であると
なんで個人かというと
因縁と煩悩の組み合わせによって
で個人になるんだと でも五蘊は五蘊であると発見します
他を攻撃する首狩り民族
首狩り民族精神は自分の無知と煩悩の仕業であると発見します
だから今まで首狩り民族でしたでしょ
ああ そういうことか みんな五蘊だけで煩悩で人間ができているんだと
だから個性はあるんだけど
結局は共通しているんだと
でも首狩り性格はなくなるんです
生命とは名色 ナーマルーパですね
心と物質でできていること
どんどん共通性に行くんです
五蘊から 一切生命は無数にあるんだけど
みんなナーマとルーパだけ
心と物質だけやと これは因縁によって現れて消えていくことを発見します
心と物質でできている
一切の現象の共通した特色は無常・苦・無我であると発見します
この智慧によって執着が消えて解脱に達します
これはブッダのプログラムです
煩悩がない人に差別感情はありません
これで完了 もう差別はないんです
しかし 優れた区別能力があります
だって区別能力から智慧が現れて
それから共通点を見つけて
それから特色を見つけたでしょ
能力があります だから悟りに達した人の知識に
能力に人間誰だって敵わないんです
ということで じゃあ仏教が嫌い
エリートのためにも一つ教えてあげないとね
世の中仏教嫌いは多いんだからね
同一なものは何一つも存在しないと理解してください
自分の希望 我儘 自我意識に合わせて全世界変えてみることは成り立たないといい加減理解してください
仏教は嫌いでいいんです
あなたの我が儘で世界は変えませんよ
攻撃して潰すこともできない
世界は それは世界一愛着する自分自身を破壊する道だと理解する
仏教は嫌いな人です 自分が攻撃的になって
嫌なものを全部壊してやる
世界は私の己の欲しいように変えてみると思ったら
自分自身が破壊する だって仏教嫌いな人々っていうのは
ものすごく自分に愛着があるでしょ
自分に愛着があったら自分を守ってください
差を認める立派な人間になる
差を認める立派な人間になってください
この人には髪の毛がない
この人には歯が 歯は落ちているとかね
まあ歳だから歯がないねとか
それだけ あんた足が弱いねとかね
じゃあすへ座ってくださいと
それだけの人生でしょうに
これはエリートの生きる道です
エリートならこういう生き方やってほしい
やってないんだったら
エリートと嘘を言わないでほしい
それき仏教と 仏教とだと自称する人のために
私はあえて辛口悪口で書いているんです
それは自称するだけで仏教になりません
他の宗教みたいに出てください
いらっしゃってください
仏教徒になってください
ないんです 仏教は はい
仏教徒だと自称したければ
まず 第1個人の差を認めましょう
自分の性格さえ変えられないのに
他人の性格 自分の希望で変えようとする恐ろしい残酷な生き方をやめる
当たり前でしょ 攻撃したいという感情を泣きながらでも慈しみで制御する
誰かに馬鹿にされたら
もう悔しくても慈しみを育ててください
仏教徒だと言いたければ
攻撃しない 馬鹿にされているのに
足を引っ張っているのに
やっぱりそれでもその人々が幸せでありますようにと
頑張るしかないんです
すべての人間 すべての生命と仲良くすることが最高の修行であると理解する
だから 五戒守るべきか
酒飲むべきかとか それよりも先に生命と仲良くすること
最高の修行だと 戒律なんかはもう守る守ると言ったっても破っちゃうでしょうに
結局は だからそれじゃ自慢にならないんです
戒律はちょこちょこと破っちゃっても
すべての生命と仲良くすることはできるでしょ
でしょうに いや ブッダかイエスはそれからやり直せばいいでしょうに
懺悔して 仲良くすることが仏道です
よく覚えておいてください Learn
and practice tolerance. 英語で言えば Discipline
your uncompromising mind. このuncompromising mind
全くもう許すことをしない
折り合わない 頑固な心をdiscipline
戒めなさいと tolerance
という寛容を修行しましょうっていうのは仏教の道です
で これで終わりと思います
はい ありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
後藤と申します 会員になってから結構経ってるんですけども
いつも先生の本のファンで
よく拝読させてもらっています
今回 日本の未来という新刊を読ませてもらってるんです
それで気になったことなんですけども
あの以前からスマナサーラ先生は
スマナサーラ先生のご判断で
アメリカは悪い国だとオピニオンでよくおっしゃってると思うんですけども
あの この本の中では 中国を触れ触れられていると思うんですけどもね
あの古い国であって 日本の天皇制も行政も
全て中国のコピーだ コピーだし
日本の言葉の文字は中国の文字じゃないかと
で あの六十四ページですね
日本人は歴史ある中国をいつでも兄貴分として先輩として見なくてはいけませんと断言されてるんですよ
なんでアメリカよりも中国の方を兄貴分と見るべきだと断言されてる
そこら辺のことをちょっと詳しくご説明をお願いしたいんですけど
別に私から個人的にはどんな国もくだらんといえばくだらんですから
人間はね まあ感情的だから
でも我々はアメリカの影響の中でね
ずっと生きてるんだから
もうちょっと紳士的にしてよと言いたいんですよ
だって日本人 日本国ってアメリカとすごく仲がいいでしょうに
他の国よりもアメリカと仲良くやりたいでしょうね
これであれこれとカラコロやっちゃいますよね
だから誰だって同じなんですよ
この人偉くて この人っていうのは
これは言えないんですね
だから例えば日本人の気持ちはよくわかってますよ
日本人の気持ちわかるんだけど
私がもうそこ別なところからいて
やっぱり日本が潰れるのは嫌なんですね
日本人は負けるのは嫌なんですね
やっぱり堂々と生きてほしいしね
それだったら あれやこれやと手を回していろんなことでいかにして仲良くするのかということで考えなくちゃあかんですね
そこが僕が仏教的に見ているんだからね
そこは私が言いたいポイントなんです
別に中国はいい国だと言ってるわけじゃないんです
承知いたしました  我々はこの相手国の悪いところばっかり考えちゃうと
どんどん問題が大きくなっちゃうんですね
だから  どうすれば仲良くなるのか
どうすれば仲良くなるのかとね
頑張った方がいいんですね
ヒンドゥー教は当然古いし
だから仏教とヒンドゥー教は仲良くやってます
だからヒンドゥー教の人々は
もうこれはもう後からできた仏教
ヒンドゥー教の一部やと
向こうも仲間に入れてるし
私たちも仏教でもヒンドゥー教の神も結構拝んでるんだよと
お互いに結構喧嘩しますよ
一緒にご飯食べながら
ごちゃごちゃ喧嘩しながら仲良くやってます
ただ 古いだけは証拠になりませんね
どちらが有効で 例えば中国は歴史古いんだけど
もう最近まで日本の技術はあれやこれやとかね
コピーしてコピーして発展したでしょうに
だからそれは事実ですよ
今 中国は誰からもコピーしない
もう自分たち技術を持ってるしね
まあだからライバルにした方があまり良くない
誰だってね アフリカの国々も中東の国々も
やっぱりライバルに回すとあかんですよ
とにかく仲間にしなくちゃ
今 あの あまり日本で言ってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
日本の総理大臣がいろんなアジアのあちこちスリランカにも行くみたいですね
あれって何なのかとか
国連のなんとかの会議にメンバーシップを取ろうとしてるでしょ
日本は そちらに投票してくださいって話なんですね
常任理事国  常任理事国
そちらに投票してくださいっていうことでね
だからやっぱり仲良くした方がいいでしょう
これ仲良くする 日本がちょっと心配しているのは心配
誤解しているのは この仲良くするためにはすごく金がかかってダメージを受けるんじゃないかなと
それはないんです やっぱり人間
みんな人間同士だ こんにちはとかね
そういう雰囲気を作れば
まあ貧しい国々 困っている国々は当然日本は助けているんだからね
それは全然問題ないしね
ただ この仲良くすることをあまりやらないっていうのは
私の困っているところなんです
大丈夫です  もうひと方ぐらい
じゃあ真ん中の  最後の全ての生き物と仲良くやっていきたいと私も心思ってるんですけど
ここにもありますように
生きとし生けるものの幸せを願っているつもりなんですけど
そうすると食生活において肉
肉を食べれなくなってきたんですね
確かに植物はやっぱりそれも命をいただくんですけど
それを食べないと死んでしまうので
植物はいただくんですけど
動物を食べるということを場合はどう考えてばいいでしょうか
あの これはちょっとややこしいポイントなんですけど
あの 仏教でいうのは殺すなよと
それで人類に殺すなよと言ったっても
こんなのは人権侵害だから
だから仏教徒になる場合は個人の主権でしょ
仏教の場合はね だから自分がブッダの教えを実践したければ
自分で仏教徒にならなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると私が殺生しないと決めるだけなんですね
友達も殺生してるんだったらやめてよと言うのは構わない
だからといってデモをやったり
いろんな看板書いて殺生やめ
それはダメです で それで人間っていうのは食べるものはだいたい死んでるんですね
キャベツも切ったりしていたりしてね
で 生でそのまま取ってパクパク食べないしね
我々肉魚食べる場合はもう命はひとかけらもないんですね
だからもう焼いているしね
いろんなことをして品物しか体に入れてないんですね
やっぱりその時もキャベツを作ったね
百姓さんたちもよく頑張って
だから優しい気持ちで作った方がいいんですね
だから私もたまたまではなくて食べますけど
もうむちゃくちゃ食べることはないんだけど
なんかすごく悲しいというかね
この生命が死んで この遺体が残って
この遺体の一部をね 自分の命に命をつなげるために助かっているんだとね
だから幸福でありますように
すべての生命が幸せでありますようにと思ってやってほしい
特に肉魚食べる場合は
この殺して食べたらあかんですね
お釈迦様の答えもいつでも生きている生き物が幸せでありますようにという気持ちで食べてくださいと
命を支えるために それしか解決策はありませんと
肉の破片一つ食べただけで殺生しているわけではないし
生命に残酷なことをやっているわけでもないんです
しかし 日本人の趣味があるでしょ
魚釣りとかね あれは残酷です
あれには私は結構悪口言います
でね もう例えばカツオという魚がありますね
その魚の破片一部しか買わないんですよ
我々はね でっかいカツオそのまま買ったりもしないし
だからそれ食べたんだからといって殺生したことにもならないし
心汚れたことにもならない
でも魚は食うためにあるんだよと思ったら
魚の人権侵害しているんですね
本当は申し訳ないことをやってるんだという気持ちが欲しいんですね
だからご飯食べる時は慈しみを念じて食べてください
そうすると問題ないと思います
はい はい あと一人方ぐらいで大丈夫です
もし質問があれば挙手していただければ
マイク あ はい  ありがとうございます
今の食料のお話の続きです
牛の肉を食べていいという前提で
今の社会システムが成り立っているわけですが
もう工場で作るような形で牛が飼育されて
それを食しております
もうこういう殺生をシステムとして組み込んでいる社会で生きているわけなんですが
そういう中で私たちはどう感じながら生きていけばいいんでしょうか？ うーん
答えは 2つありますよ
いくら社会はそういうシステムを作ったからといって
社会は悟っているわけでもないしね
もう恐ろしい首狩り民族でしょ
人類はね だからそれは正しいとは言えないんですよ
本当は魚取ってね 漁師で
それは社会が決めたことだからね
我々はハメられているんだから
うーん だから仏教的な答えは
そういう罪に嵌められる生き方はもうきっぱりやめましょうよと
金がなくても ちょっと困ったってもいいんじゃないんですか
でも心清らかだからということでね
地獄に落ちるよりは ちょっとこの世でね
金に苦労したってもいいんじゃないかと
そういう慈しみで罪にならない修行を選ぶということもできるね
特に仏教徒で頑張る場合は
より真面目に頑張りたければ
修行を選ぶ羽目にはなります
仕事を選ぶ羽目になります
それも無理な方々はもう一生懸命慈悲の瞑想して
慈悲の瞑想して この殺される生命にもね
すごく穏やかな気持ちを与えてあげて
もう他の罪は一切やめた方がいい
私は今とっくに一つの罪を犯しているんだよと
だからこれは家族にご飯をあげなくちゃあかんだからね
これも罪なのに だから他の罪は絶対しませんと
頑張る方法もあります
慈悲の瞑想をすることとね
これ難しいことですけどね
理論的に言うのはいたって簡単ですよ
やめなさいとね でも理論
やっぱり気持ちはね 生命の人権というか
尊厳ですね 我々は守った方がいいんですね
私は経験で知ってますから
この漁師たちやらね まあ他の動物を殺す人ってのは
自分がその動物のおかげで生きてるでしょうに
それは品物と思っているんですね
あれ 面白い番組 ちょこっとテレビで見ていて
ある人がこの外国から動物館
動物園関係でとかね いろんな珍しい大物の動物とか
その人が先に預かっちゃうんですね
預かって面倒見るんです
あの検疫機関とかいろいろありますからね
で 結構上手なんですよ
凶暴な動物 いろんなもう全然へっちゃらで
ちゃんと面倒見てどうやってあんた仲良くするのかといったら
これみんな私と同じ生命ですと
だから可愛いと思ってるんだと
だから問題ないんだと
そこでかなり土地があってね
そこでこの豚とか鶏もいたんですね
言ったら こういう これはどういうこと？あ
これは食料 何のこれ？それは食料
なんだこれはと 本当に立派なその世界の知識人で
プロで 動物の扱いの場合はね
問題ないんだけど 突然の外国から来た凶暴な野生の動物であっても
本人がちゃんと面倒見てあげて
検疫期間終わったらちゃんと元に戻してあげたりしますよ
しかし 自分もシステムの中で生きていて
自分が食べる豚肉は自分で殺して食べていて
チキンもこれは食料 ...っていう
それはちょっとどうかなとね
うーん やっぱり生命のね
尊厳をたとえ殺して食べてもね
認めた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
それしか答えられません
私には 慈悲の瞑想をしてください
とにかくそうするとできる罪っていうのは結構
結構消えます 慈悲が入ってくればくるほど
罪は人間には完璧に生きることはできませんからね
誰だって間違いはしますしね
私もいろいろ間違いはするしね
完璧にはなりません で
しかし 慈悲を実践すると
慈悲と慈悲の気持ちでいると
間違いを犯しても まあそんなに大げさなことにならないんですね
それから生命の尊厳をね
やっぱり認めてやりましょう
たとえ魚を食べても  頑張ってください
それ以上は言えません
ありがとうございました
はい それではちょうど時間となりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで廻向の文を唱えたいと思いますので
覚えている方は一緒に唱えてください
では合掌してください
廻向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティオーイガンジャントーサンベローオーイナッサトーマーテーバワットアンテラーヨサテーディーガーエコーバウェーバウトサッベマンディランラッカン
トサンバデバタサンバブッダヌーバヴェーナサンバダンマーヌーバヴェーナサンバサンガーヌーバヴェーナ
サダーサッティーバワントテーアビワダナシーリスーニッチャンワッダーバチャーイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーアウィワンノーすたんばらん
ありがとうございます